A long time ago, there lived a king and a queen in a palace.
They had everything except a baby.
"I really want a baby", said the queen.
So do I. Let's hope we have one soon.
Many years went by and finally they had a pretty princess.
How great!
She is as beautiful as the morning sunlight.
Oh! I want to call her Aurora since she was born at dawn.
That's wonderful!
I'll hold a big christening for her.
The king decided to invite all the fairies so they could give her good wishes.
"Messenger, write invitations to the sky fairy, the flower fairy, the tree fairy and the water fairy", said the king.
Is that all, my lord?
Wait! Include the mountain fairy, the field fairy, the sunshine fairy and the moonlight fairy.
I think that's all.
Okay, my lord. I'll send letters to them right away.
But they forgot to invite the bad weather fairy, Zelda.
Zelda was an old and grumpy fairy.
"Why didn't they invite me?", said Zelda to herself.
She heard about the christening and came to the palace.
After the christening, everyone sat down for dinner.
Oh dear, here comes Zelda.
We forgot to invite her.
I'm very sorry.
Please sit down and have dinner with us.
Bring another chair and bring her a cup and a plate.